welcome back to new rock stars with the
big game coming this weekend we're
hoping for some delicious new trailers
in between whatever sports stuff will be
going on uh they're they're playing polo
right it's
golf or one of those things and
hopefully that means a fresh look at the
multiverse of madness maybe hopefully
please football gods bless us with some
hot new scarlet witch america chavez and
mordo the sorcerer killer content please
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we adore my name is mt and
going wrong with me today is the
practitioner of her own form of chaos
magic it's whitney van lane and what's
going on with me
just practicing some chaos magic you
know me that enough chaos in this world
i say just kidding
too much we live in a calm time you guys
things are really chill exactly a real
chill time i feel like in comparison to
uh to us the mcu is just really chill
and smashing star-shaped holes in every
dimension while hosting the mass effect
adventum podcast it's matt acevedo
what's going on homie
who's ready for some chaos control
oh chaos control oh
you know
i think you're talking about the chaos
that's right do you mean
the chaos emeralds because i have them
right here chaos control
and someone who is always letting things
get out of hand it's off-screen producer
brandon what's going on brandon
ah yes hello things
got out of hand okay
give me that
sharp little one hair coming down you
know doctor strange always
two hairs coming down yeah it's like
strands ah bless the makeup artist for
dr strange because i always get those
strands just
bristling in the wings exactly his hair
got a little bit out of hand he's like
oh oh it's so mad i'm just literally you
give him the curl and then give him
glasses like who is this man yeah yeah
right right
it's a bird it's a plane oh no it's evil
doctor strange
and hey we're all anxiously awaiting the
next mcu film doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and the one thing
that remains the biggest mystery is the
tease of this evil doctor strange which
leads us to our first topic of the day
who is this strange variant in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
because as we see in the current doctor
strange trailer we see an evil sinister
version of our less menacing former
sorcerer supreme but just who is this
version of strange a variant an imposter
a crossover from the what if series when
we saw the that doctor strange ruin his
reality and get trapped in that little
prison reality because the synopsis of
the film from marvel japan says to
restore a world where everything is
changing strange seeks the help from his
ally wong the sorcerer supreme and the
avengers most powerful scarlet witch
wanda but a terrible threat lubes over
humanity and the entire universe that no
longer can be done by their power alone
even more surprising the greatest threat
in the universe looks exactly like
doctor strange benedict cumberbatch so
before we potentially see any more
footage from this film over the weekend
which i hope to god we do please kevin
feige do it we have to ask just who is
this version of doctor strange what do
you guys think okay well purely based on
that very stylized strand of hair alone
i believe
that the body of doctor strange has been
uh possessed by the spirit of glenn
danzig and that uh the misfits are just
raging inside of him and that's why he's
so damn dark um no you know what exactly
but in all seriousness uh my real answer
is kind of similar to that uh i think
that maybe actually i don't i don't
think that this is actually gonna happen
but it would be [ __ ] cool and i want
it to happen but what if we get leader
of the black priest doctor strange
because that would be sick
so
uh just a little quick recap for our
viewers at home uh if you don't know uh
the black priests uh are a group of guys
they're all influential magic users that
destroy specific earths in different
realities with the goal in mind of the
greater good to restabilize the
multiverse
by ridding the multiverse of worlds that
they deem are kind of [ __ ] up and so
are these with the black swans and stuff
yes
yes all right
they are with the black swans and stuff
so i think that they could
like you know this isn't in the comics
but to fit into this movie i think that
they could like bend things around and
have it be that the black priests are
coming to destroy earth because that
doctor strange like it up so much and so
our doctor strange is gonna get into a
fight with evil doctor strange because
evil doctor strange believes that this
is for the greater good and technically
it is for the greater good of the
multiverse because it's the only way to
stabilize it but obviously
stephen over here doesn't want the whole
planet nuked now does he so he's gonna
have to get [ __ ] together and fight the
hive mind army of impossible
knowledge that is the black priest and
also he's gonna look metal as hell doing
it because there's like this one still
from the comics where he's like sitting
on a throne with a gigantic skull behind
him and that's where glenn danzig comes
in boom full circle ladies and gentlemen
oh my god you know that's my favorite
i love any reference to that hickman run
i love the black swans i love that whole
multiverse like type of like cult i
don't i know it's so cool
and because dr strange when he's with
them he has the ability to shape reality
however he wants so
he's kind of a little wanda e in that
regard when he's with the black priests
and so i feel like it would be really
cool to see wanda fight
you know bad doctor strange bad boy
doctor strange um in a battle against
you know reshaping the fabric of reality
oh it'd be so cool i'm into it i want
that to happen so bad
growing up in a in a haitian christian
household i've been around a lot of uh
black priests it didn't happen to me
that way
just going to church and uh praying well
it's nothing cool like that
very uh let down
uh
my mom let me down so thank you black
priests uh step your game up i don't
know what i'm saying continue uh you
know i really love that oh
god anyway yeah that's dope
ah
yo mt i want to get real rogue here okay
i'm gonna get weird because like uh
immediately we're like i think it's
gonna be the what if version of doctor
strange and i'm like ah it seems like a
hood wing to me it seems like yeah i
don't think so it's a little bit you did
yeah so i'm gonna get let's get a little
weird okay
just follow stay with me
doctor strange isn't the sorcerer
supreme anymore right so he doesn't have
the full power of the sorcerer supreme
so in order to help wanda he's gonna do
something that wong tells him not to do
again because it seems to be the rapport
to try and get back to kind of like that
power of the sorcerer supreme so he's
gonna like have wanda help him use some
sort of enchantment to have him go into
like his own mind and like deal with
like with the power within himself which
is actually this really dark
manifestation uh and he'll come with
some sort of deal with his like really
dark version of himself within his mind
to get back the powers of the sorcerer
supreme
really weird i know i know and like
yeah but i kind of like that kind of
idea of him like literally battling his
own
a darkness within himself
you know
so i think he's going to get that power
from there listen i am uh i've given too
much of my money to the kingdom hearts
franchise for me not to like this theory
yeah i'm a big fan of fighting one's
darknesses or one's darkness has become
real i'm well i'm on board with this
homie i'm not boring yeah it's actually
he said the power that's inside i
immediately was like
what this is
[Applause]
i forgot to mention that like oh the
version of of you know steven is is his
heart that's the dark verse is actually
the vessel of heart and steven himself
is like the body of steven you know
anyways that's all kingdom hearts
nonsense
i mean that's some kingdom for sure
stephen was the nobody oh i see so he
gave his heart to darkness and if you
put an x in steven and make an anagram
out of it
brandon you gotta play kingdom hearts
bro oh i've played i've played kingdom
hearts i've played some kingdom hearts
that was our in the second one when he
just when he just yells kingdom hearts
that's like my favorite part of the
franchise when he just shouts kingdom
hearts i like when a good like tv or
movie just just says the name of the the
title he's like kingdom hearts too
i like that idea mac because he's like
cause like that that room does look like
it could be like in his mind right this
is just like yeah i like because i i
really want uh uh wanda to go full evil
and i want i love this idea that she's
using strange as like i'm not getting
through this this dark hole fast enough
i'm gonna like steal his mind and like
use it against him because
and i also think that like our doctor
strange is the evil doctor strange i've
said this before like he's the bad one
like other dimensions doctor strangers
are less
dangerous and ours is the one who's
always messing with time he's doing the
stuff in no way home he's like letting
people die when he wants them to die
like he's he he's the bad one and other
strangers are like coming to fight him
so i think that like this evil doctor
strange could be like a bad is he's our
doctor strange who's gone fully off the
deep end right he he sees christine
palmer get married and he's like this is
so messed up like this should have been
me and i'm and he becomes the evil one
should have been and and the doctor
strange that that winds up being good is
actually a skrull wizard who becomes doc
he becomes our universe is doctor
strange and wipes out the other one that
that'll get resolved in uh you know
secret invasion they'll figure that all
out then but our doctor strange is going
to become it's going to be a scroll and
the evil one that we see in this trailer
is is our original dr strange who's gone
fully in because yeah i think it's too
easy to make it the what if doctor
strange and at the end of the what if
seriously it is strange supreme had
seemed to like chill out a little bit
and he was like cool so i think it's our
job i love that we're all evil
on the same page about that i love the
wrong things oh for sure yeah we're used
to this marvel these little like like
scapegoats oh we think it's nope nope
that's a distraction you know
you're talking about the power that's
the obvious
that's inside coming out that's right
fully taking over
now i really do like that idea or that
tie-in with the scrolls because we as we
know secret invasion is coming up to
disney plus and so like it would be
crazy yeah i'm too suspicious of
everyone now i'm so suspicious of
everyone you gotta be bro like you can't
trust nobody on these streets man like i
i don't even trust the boy from iron man
3. i i never tried
he just summoned his eyes yeah yeah i
don't know yeah you probably don't even
get invited to the funeral he just like
showed up and they're all like who is
this kid was he right
like don't worry
yeah tony was hanging out in my house
it's cool it's cool like he left me some
some high level technology that i
shouldn't have as a child but uh
yeah i don't trust that kid at all i
like to think that like he still brags
about that one time he met tony stark to
everybody people were like yeah we get
it yeah
yeah obviously he's gonna dine out on
that for years
it's like we know he's like that kid
from high school who only did like you
know football in high school and then
he's like you know if i if i didn't
first my ankle we wouldn't want cis
we would have gone to state bro we would
have totally gone to sleep we know we
get it we get
bar in that it that still has like the
bodies or the shadows on the wall or
whatever from the people who blew up and
he's like yeah yeah everyone who came
back from the blip that's thanks to me
because i saved tony's life yeah
people are taking photos
well
welcome to extremism come on in people
died here
but no these are all super rogue
theories i love the hickman theory i
love the idea that the kingdom hearts
darkness and i love me a skrull sorcerer
because that that is precedent there are
precedence for that in marvel comics i
believe the dioramas
are actually um
off branch of the skrulls that became
diaries because they just messed around
with magic too much so
yes there are magic uh scrolls out there
so there is precedence for that so
um i'm gonna give all of you guys five
thousand robux because oh you know so
many i just you guys are all you're
flooding the market i know so many this
is dangerous i'm flooding the market i i
went from millions to thousands to
singles dollars i'm all over the place
i'm responsible for the market crash in
2008.
the housing bubble burst because mt
wouldn't stop awarding us points exactly
[Laughter]
they trusted me a little bit a
generation in ruins
and it's all my fault
but up next we're going to talk about an
exciting new cast member joining the
ironheart series but first a great way
to support us here at new rockstars is
to grab yourself a cool short or hoodie
over at the newrockstarsmerch.com
website they've got really cool new
designs inspired by peacemaker book of
boba fett spider-man no way home and
even some weird shirts that say hi i'm
eric voss because you know you just want
to feel like i eric vos even though
you'll never be eric boss eric vosk is
the goat and uh you just you'll you'll
just pretend that you'd be a nice eric
boss cosplay that's what you just need
you to know the hierarchy there because
he's a goat so you can have a nice goat
shirt
sorry eric voss play
oh
eric boss play yes
i honestly am so sad at myself and angry
at myself for not putting that two
together so you're incredible so yes do
a little shopping get you some eric boss
play and support the channel over at new
rockstars merch
and hey if one of your goals this year
is to learn a new language our friends
at babel are here to help babble is the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions that's a
lot but now that some of us are thinking
about traveling again it's going to be
very cool to speak the language at your
vacation destination so learn how to say
more than just margarita in spanish when
you land in mexico the whole babel
process is addictively fun fast and easy
and babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons for world use and we've got
multiple folks in the new rockstars
offices using babel right now and they
all love how easy it is to use babel's
15-minute lessons make it the perfect
way to learn a new language on the go
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german plus babel's speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent i think they
even have one for the rock bottom
episode of spongebob language where you
speak like this and you just i can't
confirm that but um just look into it uh
they have they also have podcasts games
videos stories and even live classes and
plus it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee so start your new language
learning journey today with babel right
now when you purchase a three-month
bible subscription you'll get an
additional three months for free that's
six months for the price of three that's
an amazing deal you save so much money
so you can buy other things for your
life so just go to babel.com and use
promo code rogue that is b a b b e l dot
com code
rogue
r-o-g-u-e babble the language for life
now we're not always confident in our
theories here on rogue theory but you
need confidence in life and also in the
bedroom and that's where blue chew comes
in because blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets at a fraction of the
cost you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises and the
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within
days and it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made
in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discreet
package so if you could benefit for some
extra confidence when it's time to you
know get it on bluechew can help and
we've got a special deal for our
audience try blue chew free when you use
our promo code rogue at checkout just
pay five dollars shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code rogue to receive
your first month free visit bluechew.com
for more details and important safety
information and we thank bluechu for
sponsoring this show but now guys we got
some exciting casting news around the
new ironheart series this week which
leads us to our next topic of the day
who will anthony ramos be in the mcu
because news this week broke the anthony
ramos of hamilton and in the heights
fame very very talented very handsome
man will have a role in the upcoming
iron heart series on disney plus it's
not yet known who he will play but the
sources are comparing the role to that
of jonathan majors as kang who was
introduced in loki but will play a much
larger role in the mcu who do you think
anthony ramos might be portraying in the
mcu what do you guys think i really want
him to be
uh i think he's a good cast and i think
it makes sense with what i think the the
television universe is making um i think
he's gonna be nova the sam alexander
nova i think that he might be you know
and i think you know nova sam
alexander's younger right but maybe this
is an older version of him uh maybe you
know he's in his 20s right um but i do
think that the way it's going to be
introduced is that uh you know sam get
discovers his health his dad's helmet
his dad is a former nova uh he gets the
uh i might be wrong on this it's like
the black nova it's like a very powerful
nova helmet and that was his dad's um
apologies if i butchered the name of
that but he gets his dad he finds his
dad's helmet i kind of think that uh
iron heart is actually going to be
leaning more towards this mystery around
you know uh
riri is going to discover her abilities
find a tony stark tag and in the process
she'll
find uh you know sam's dad uh and the
helmet leaking back to
uh sam and together they're gonna kind
of work together uh he'll discover his
nova powers and they'll like solve this
mystery that might lead to like a cree
uh or chatari kind of like bad guy
looking for this nova source um and
teaming up to like kind of stop that and
it will also lead to what i think that
the tv series are leading to which is
the young avengers because sam was part
of the young avengers for a while so i
think he might be a part a key element
uh with miss marvel and iron heart and
and uh you know kate bishop i think
we're seeing the formation of the young
avengers so i think he's gonna be nova i
want him to be nova i think he would be
a great cast for nova even though nova
is technically like a younger character
i like that that would be
banana that's cool i would really love
that at all and like i don't think that
that's out of the question particularly
because like even if they were to go
with the younger sam alexander at the
end of the day we have time travel as a
factor here so like he i would love to
see him even if that doesn't happen like
as a mainstay just as like i'm a future
version of nova nova's coming soon but
here's me and like this is what i look
like in the future um i love that that'd
be dope as hell i love that idea well i
think that you know we have iron heart
coming this is the spiritual successor
to tony stark you know iron man so i
think i would like to see anthony ramos
get a turn as a villain too a little
more evil so i think you know
it might be someone from from tony's
past that tony didn't know was there and
i think that anthony ramos is gonna be
ezekiel stain good old zeke stain you
that's what i wanted
too
especially with the connection to the
ten rings because as the ten rings are
gonna be rising into power again i mean
they've always been there in the
background but you know you have uh
wenwu's daughter taking over you know
the ten rings now at the end of shanxi
uh
and and there's a lot of history in the
comics with zeke stain and the ten rings
uh and i could see like
you know zeke being this guy who you
know obadiah when he was flying around
the world working with the ten rings you
know
we never know who zeke's mom is you know
he zeke is the son of obadiah maybe in a
strange son maybe obadiah didn't even
know he had this son and he sees like
the legacy that tony left behind but
tony killed his dad man he's pissed and
he wants a little revenge and he's super
smart uh and you know the ten rings
maybe they bust him out of jail just
like they did in the comics and he comes
for a little revenge he shows up at mit
and he's like i'm gonna mess some stuff
up uh and riri has to put him down i
don't know if zeke is a big enough
character to have like a long reign in
the mcu maybe maybe they're gonna make
his turn to evil come later maybe he's
presented as like a good character in
the show and we see the turn come a
little later uh but yeah i would love
for
you know obadiah stay and son to come
get a little revenge and bring the iron
monger back and do the iron manga again
let him be like iron monger two or
something like that uh i think that
would be a lot of fun because i'd like
to see him play a bad guy uh
in this show i think that would be great
i would really love to see ezekiel stain
come up because like you know it's i've
been sort of waiting for that for a
while because like stain was a big
presence in the iron man mythos and like
since he died in iron man one i'm just
like what is that name gonna come back
any other way and so like and like i
really like what you said about you know
marvel sort of introducing him as a good
person because like we sort of see that
with the druid in the eternals because
we know in the comics he's like
historically an evil person but now like
we sort of have like introduced him as
like oh he's a really nice guy even
makari they're so cute together look at
that he's not gonna disappoint you at
all in the future um so yeah i think i
would love to see that type of deal with
ezekiel just having a relationship
without like a relationship but like a
friendship with ironheart and then like
us falling in love with this dude and
just being like oh no he's evil oh
there's the jungle right writers yeah i
think that would also mean like you know
pepper who's running stark industries is
also being into some sort of legal
dispute as well so
i think this is next
guys we talked about a lot a lot of
legal stuff in the next phase of the mcu
i'm telling you it sure is it's it's
true
in here very very clear what you got
whitney okay so this is a
fully rogue
um
so hear me out so i think
if i'm wrong about this internet people
don't kill me i think that it's issue
eight
of iron heart um so one of her early
missions in the comics was to go to
latveria to do battle with lucia von
bardas and bartis is the cyborg
[ __ ] assassin to the and she's
the prime minister of latveria and she
is basically dr doom's right-hand
woman so
what if cause what i really held on to
from that statement was kang level right
so i was like okay well who is gonna be
kang level and how could they do it and
so i'm wondering if they're gonna do it
like a loki situation where they're
going to introduce him in the show but
it's not like you know his big deal yet
like he's gonna obviously go on to have
like a movie and all that but i think
that in the same way that they
introduced kane this could be a way
because they could send her to liberia
she could tussle with lucia a little bit
and uh take it from there because then
also sorry i keep talking i keep
thinking of new things um she could also
sorry i just keep being like wait and
then there's more uh you think i'm done
talking but guess what i never am ah
this is what i'm like all the time
so i think that also this could help
introduce like doom via his like
scientific and engineering expertise
right because she's gonna find the stark
tech and i think that it would be really
cool to see her
have to face off against like the
doombots and stuff like that using her
little her newfound stark tech situation
okay i promise i'm done now that's it
wait so like so you think anthony ramos
is going to play this character
i think anthony ramos might be doctor
doom
like fights against her at one point so
if they do that storyline where she has
to fight her and she's like his
right-hand woman then that could be how
they introduce him oh that would be sick
yeah
sorry if that was jumbled i get excited
and i talk too fast oh no no that is
literally my entire personality so i
have a good it was a good reputation i
just got lost that's why we're friends
empty i get you man i get you on like a
cellular level
i love the idea too that he could be
like a a transfer student or something
you know how like uh uh this is a bad
example but like north korea you know
kim jong-un sent like his kids to like
uh western schools like if he's like
victor von doom getting sent out to like
uh you know mit to be to learn how to be
like a normal person and not be raised
in this weird dictatorship of liberia or
something and he's like oh you know my
dad sent me here to mit i know he's
crazy you know my country's a little
nuts but then he like slowly turns into
doctor doom you know imagine having a
group project with kim jong-un jr that
should be crazy he's like venting to
riri is like
yeah i just can't stand my my lab
partner you know uh really reeves
[Music]
oh this guy's the worst he's the worst
and she was like what's your name and
he's like my name's victor
you're like oh
they make him like the mask he's like
the mascot at the school or whatever i
don't know what mit's mascot is but like
something happens and he gets fused
inside of the mascot suit and becomes
like uh dr doom that way i think that dr
doom is the mascot of mit i mean it
should be probably
i i feel like uh tony stark gave enough
money to that school for the for the
mascot to be iron man oh yeah yeah like
there's everybody we have so much fun at
mit that even the mascot has like a nano
suit you know what i mean
instead of like the mascots who's with
the giant head no but that but the one
that the mascot has does have a giant
head and that's what separates it from
other nanotech suits
but no these are all super rogue fairies
i like i especially love the this idea
that anthony ramos could be a sam
alexander nova because i love sam
alexander that is my favorite version of
nova i honestly think that if nova does
come to the mcu i just i do want the kid
version ideally uh but i just want any
sam alexander because he's just one dude
um so i'm gonna give you i don't know
seven thousand robux for that one and
then the market's crashing empty come on
get the right button the market is going
out of control dude i can't i i will not
be stopped and oh my god 16. i vibe with
zeke over diastain hardcore so my friend
brandon you're going to get 8 000. oh
baby
if he is doing zeke stain i hope that
anthony really goes for like the
impression and like throws on the voice
and is like riri so nice to meet you
riri
make him shave his head and grow a beard
or something i'm feeding for some doctor
doom we all finished for some doctor
doom and so like i would love to see
you know a younger doctor doom pop up i
would like to see a take from that from
anthony ramos but so i'm gonna give you
seven thousand points for that one too
because that was pretty dang
[Music]
i kind of wanted i kind of wanna get
sorry back thinking of the zeke thing i
kind of want him to be like you know she
built she built an iron man suit in her
garage with a box of scraps
of spare parts like he can't say it
exactly seriously if they don't bring up
the the whole box of scraps thing are
you really his son yeah yeah i don't
know when you're not his real biological
child that's some that that shit's in
your dna dude that's not a personality
trait
that's who you are
for that one also mt you said you wanted
to see a young doctor doom but didn't we
see a young doctor wasn't there a
fantastic four movie a few years ago
where we saw a younger doctor doom what
maybe i had a dream was that when i was
maybe yeah one night that was the gas
that was fantastic okay okay and then
there was the rise of silver surfer that
might have been and then there was
there's 2012 in the world right yeah
yeah yeah i think that was that period
yeah i wasn't maybe i made it up i don't
know listen i'm scarlet whit and i'm
erasing the other one from the
multiverse anthony ramos is it
i love it but now it is time for our
rogue question are you ready guys
yes
we're about to go real rogue here
because we're going to talk about the
batman the robert battenson batman
gq article robert batchenson admitted
that he was surprised to find out that
batman was also known as the world's
greatest detective even though batman is
very much known for that and detective
comics is what dc stands for but anyway
what are some of the rogues other things
that mr battenson also was surprised to
discover about the batman
here's what i think i think he was like
you know because you can't make a batman
movie without the death of the parents
right we got to see the alleyway we got
to see the pearls flying in the air we
got to see the roses hit the ground
right we got to have a kiss from a rose
on the gray uh i think where robert
found out
i think get seal in here get stealing on
this
no i think robert pad said when you find
what he when he's like reading the
script or he's he's on set and they
mention the fact that like you know uh
bruce wayne's parents were killed he was
like what
what he was like totally shocked to find
out
the most well-known thing in comic book
history that bruce wayne parents uh were
were gunned down
after a a movie or an opera or whatever
whatever form of theater you choose they
were murdered in an alleyway he was
shocked to find out that bruce wayne did
not have his parents anymore they got
murdered after seeing the blue man group
and this one yeah i mean like if this if
this the batman if the batman takes
place in like a 2020. we never know when
batman movies take place
the dark knight we have a good idea but
if like the batman takes place in 2020
yeah like his parents were killed after
they went and saw like gladiator or the
matrix i don't i don't know what what
they were going to see
his parents were killed after a
lackluster night at ucb
yeah
his parents saw asscat and they got
murdered in the street afterwards and
they got murdered afterwards
they all watched uh idiocracy and uh
they were just like you know what this
is too real we gotta get we gotta go
what if the last thing they saw was just
stevo's dick in jackass they went and
saw jack
just the honeybees all over it
yes
it was so horrible martha's like let's
let's leave early i don't i don't want
to stay for this whole movie it's just a
bunch of jackets
and then bruce becomes traumatized and
becomes b-man instead
yes
b-man
not the bees
i fear the bees the most i became
no that's really that's that's really
fun i really like the idea of him just
not knowing about the biggest batman
most important of all time that'd be
really funny uh you know i kind of think
that robert pattinson didn't know that
batman's mom was also named martha
what my friend's mom's named martha what
are the odds and they kind of like blood
stop everything stop everything you're
telling me what
that can't be
that can't be oh my god i love that so
much i love a good martha reference i'll
never forget when i heard that the first
time i was like wait what
what
martha saves lives martha speaks for
real yeah i will say that i've met i met
other people whose mom's name is lisa
and i was like that didn't like phase me
you know i was like oh yeah man yeah but
were you trying to kill them what are
they trying to kill i don't know that's
kind of weird matt
if i'm afraid if i'm never tell me
if i'm ever being held up at like
gunpoint or someone's trying to kill me
i'm just going to throw out my mom's
name to see if it works that's my last
stitch let's see if it works yeah i know
absolutely that's what you should do in
any fight
you just start shouting a's martha
selena
[Laughter]
[Music]
what you got whitney all right
you guys do you even want me to say i
know i have a feeling
yeah
robert pattinson was just as surprised
as all of us to learn that batman
doesn't eat puppy
oh my god you know what that's what i
thought about when i first said the
question that he learned that and
immediately was like well that's
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] absolutely that's
[ __ ] you know what that's what i
said too he's a hero you know he's a
hero and heroes
do that
yeah exactly they take their support
women that is the number one thing that
heroes do
just let batman go downtown on a nice
lady i mean that's all i want for him
and you know what dc i have a bone to
pick with that because you said that
heroes don't do that but what about
matter eater lad huh he could eat
anything he could eat literally i don't
think it's safe for him to do it it
could be dangerous i don't yeah i don't
think that i would want that from him
specifically oh no no no specifically no
like if we're ranking who i want
he's way down the list man
whitney i guarantee that robert
pattinson went to like wb and went he
had a meeting with the held ahead
honchos and he's like look
i know what you're gonna tell me batman
doesn't do and he's going to do it in
this movie okay and he's going to do
that
we're going to put it in the booth
that's why this the first kind of movie
we're going to put it in the movie it's
going to be rated nc 17.
we're going to establish
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know what i am a big fan i think
that that is actually the most likely
because yeah it is probably the most
shocking batman fact that truly is a
truly most shocking canon i've ever
heard ever like in any universe in any
pretty much since we got the canon image
of batman's penis um a couple of years
back um
in a recent what was it batman damn yeah
batman oh yeah
oh i thought you were talking about when
we see ben affleck's penis in gonzaga
and gondro and i was like seen him too
so i guess i've seen two bat dicks yeah
yeah yeah
yeah sure collect them like at this
point like thanos yeah catch them all
right
that comic was was very good that was a
very good comment
the batman damn not just that page
primarily the first printings i mean the
the
exactly like after the second printings
when they remove the paper the quality
of the comment just went really yeah
they they're really
quality how much money can i make
why honestly like if you have the penis
copy i it's probably worth more now yeah
it pays to have a comic pool every time
your penis comes in the reprint exactly
always get that poll always show up to
your comic book shop on wednesday
because you never know you never know
you might get some bargain basement
batman dick waiting for you
[Laughter]
this is chaos that's that's gonna be
another drink at the moment
did i murder him t is he dead is he dead
as a person who's been too many bargain
basement comic book places like it's
just hilarious
wow
it's the worst place that you ever
wanted like ever run into a penis i'm
telling you it's the the body odor is
it's for real anyway here we go that is
it for this episode
of rogue theory thank you to our guests
you gotta hand out some more one oh yes
i i didn't even reward points i'm just
completely big and dummy where's your um
answer maddie oh martha the pair he
didn't know the parents got killed
[Laughter]
and if you don't remember mine it was
put
it was pushed up yes he's got a woman
i got it
in the cat for a reason you know i'll
donate all my points i have to give
100 million points to whitney
for that answer because i'm sorry it is
the most realistic answer and i feel
like someone should ask him yeah someone
should ask robert pans if he knows this
fact i think so blown away we gotta we
gotta get new rock stars on the press
junket for this one because we gotta ask
him we gotta ask yeah we gotta get on
the junket just to ask him that i'm on
my way boss asking the question
empty you'll do it it's like a local um
reporter mp
[Laughter]
but that makes whitney our big winner of
the day because she just i just love
that answer a lot support your women
everybody
but that is it for this episode of rogue
theory thank you to our lovely guests
whitney van laningham matt acevedo and
off-screen producer brandon always on
the screen support our channel by
checking out all of our awesome merch
over at newestrockstarsmerch.com you can
follow me at mastertainment if you want
to see between some really weird [ __ ]
and really weird theories and also you
can support new rockstars by going to
newrockstarsmerge.com and also just
hanging out with us on discord because
we have some really fun things going on
over there so just come hang out and
have a party and this is type of type of
joke
type of thing over here and just
type us a little joke
big question suggestions it's so much
fun so head on over to discord right
there but you have to be 18 years older
because we'd be saying some adult things
like